[Applaudissements]
bah oui parce que on est content de
revoir vincent mais alors il y avait
aussi bill dandy l'invention n'est
peut-être pas vu depuis quelques années
et les équipes de matthieu delormeau
grâce à son tellement vrai ça lui
manquait de refaire tellement vrai à
mathieu s'est déjà lancé une nouvelle
version regarder s'ils ont retrouvé
c'est à lui et loulou c'est matthieu
delormeau
mais ils sont douzièmes prendre des
râteaux par hanouna sur d8 aujourd'hui
dans tellement musclé on a retrouvé la
trace de ben îles du bic jean louis
cette ancienne légende de la télé
qu'est-il devenu
qui sa vie loin des projecteurs savez
vous planter des choux à la mode de chez
nous nous l'avons retrouvé un document
exclusif pendant ce temps là pour moi
cuisses abdos fessiers
c'est dans la banlieue parisienne loin
des frasques de la jet set que nous
retrouvons bill qui nous reçoit chez lui
depuis la fin de l'émission l'ancien
acolyte de vincent lagaf a décidé de
s'éloigner des plateaux télé en quête
d'authenticité
les groupes il reprenait devant un
studio pour composer un petit bobo après
affronté avec villa tirer définitivement
un trait sur cette époque
désormais il a décidé de se mettre au
service des hommes et il est plus
heureux que jamais quand on apprend même
si ses vieux réflexes reprennent parfois
le dessus
bonjour je cherche un truc trop
peut-être oui et j'ai dit aux autres
volets du rideau
loridon leridon nous vidons et après
tant d'années villes gardent encore un
regard plein de tendresse sur cette
époque qui marquera à jamais cette voie
je suis toujours proche de ramuntcho est
déjà fait et vous avez des nouvelles de
vincent lagaf
non mon ami vincent tu me regarde je
vais te défoncer et même si les gens le
reconnaissent parfois encore dans la rue
pour leur bile a le regard tourné vers
l'avenir
il prépare son come back là j'ai croisé
série noire dans la rue où il m'a même
proposé d'être chroniqueur dans tes pnv
c'était il ya quatre ans j'attends qu'il
m'appelle
[Musique]
un trou
sachez que depuis ce reportage bill a
refait sa vie avec pepita de pyramide la
semaine prochaine pas de sujet vous
pourrez tout simplement regarder mes
abdos pendant 25 minutes parce que je me
kiffe hashtag narcissisme et psyché pas
ce que ça veut dire
[Applaudissements]